[Applause]
Tatom comes up with the steal
he's got numbers on the break Brown to
the basket
Chuy's percentage is pretty low
rebounds Rochdale +5 tonight
[Music]
good star attack ability and he didn't
really know what to do it it gets in the
paint
[Music]
[Applause]
to the basket
Williams has to kick it back out Tatum
comes up in to steal
[Applause]
the bench is that break earlier found
pass big flush jaylen brown or it could
succeed in the game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the basket and it goes
crowd dispatch turn skits to
had to miss Manion they took advantage
of it they have despot he wants the tree
native on the offensive glass
[Applause]
gets true out of it Bowery Antioch of 27
to Peace Walker person baseline Walker
to ball Ausmus
Pascal 33 points Tina
[Applause]
so just to translate that winter wiper
just means to garden nothing to call
their Mike butter which Weber often he
wants to ball it hit the paint kick out
hit the paint kick out go side to side
we're watching go past not duping right
there and whooping there's a hacker
ubiquity astounding the Knicks right
there got a hand washing me move to mix
along the baseline Martha Coakley giving
up the baseline table to shoot one
they've had their confrontation all
evening bars has been winning that
battle but not this time
[Applause]
3,000 controls it down they just
couldn't grab the ball you Williams the
critic keeping that ball alive and
rebound that he's saved and brown they
ended up getting the dunk now Brown
reciprocates and they watch this Mars
denied him so he's at the line for the
misfire but look at Walker moving and
grooving nicely off the glass dancing
prancing drawn a couple of Nicks and
Williams smart with a little bit of
sauce Tatum inside I don't blame Jason
Tatum I thought that could have been a
man line Walker
Heights
tired of books nineteen they have dug in
on the defensive side
go ahead Jason title run Tatum trailing
and transition a block on one end walk
into the three give Boston the lead tell
you in the third quarter the highest so
far this season and if there was a time
for Tatum to find his jumper it would be
now that plays hard place for each other
shares the ball mr. Tatum with authority
Heyward making place she's doing work
[Music]
ankles peanut sauce we're gonna
typically go Tatom with a hot head
unstoppable and
laying in the game this is just pure
talent take a look between the legs
going right to left but steps battle
this game or a number of levels is
passing pretty slick
[Music]
156 to go
[Music]
Tatom rocking the house
ball skills but he could score the
basketball deep three from Walker goes
[Applause]
grip go scam it home love this play I
mean no wasted motion whatsoever but you
really drove up to God's if you see
grant Williams it was a big part if not
the biggest part of this out to join
over Milwaukee did I with the way he
just kind of ran the offense Kemba
Walker pulls up good luck to Tatum
[Applause]
look look at him a tribe look at his
head look at his eyes he's off good cuff
I hated Bing himself available on that
play such a smart play by Jason Tate Oh
22 on the night for Tatum now all right
here we go
smart looking looking for Tatum gets it
in Tatum takes
[Applause]
a lot of fun no question look at this
shot I mean no space to work the game at
3 or 1 to 2 but look at JC tail wastes
no time at all being downloaded seven
points season like that not bad that
means a defense is doing something but
it'd be a one-on-one defenses including
the problem here in this first port on
this floor suffer the injury tossing the
entire season Nats inside puts it up
blocked by the lengthy Tatom being a
writer lieutenant to Chicago and there's
the drop gonna need potatoes introduced
himself
see this Cavaliers crowd they're the
preseason has mentioned 26 points is
Tatum knocks down a baseline jumper
[Applause]
there you go one big step into three
inhale and that worried about then
Tristan Thompson please take the gap
[Applause]
well Cassie get it to me I'll take it
yeah I mean you're you're really in
trouble
chadzmuth another rune Tatum flash by
Dellavedova morals of the theme ready
boom him in on looks zero and wine it go
turns back number zero bring in white
Walker contestant 304 me word again
Brown
nice move back from his illness and got
the deuce with balance on that jump shot
as well
[Applause]
finally got wondergirl and Kevin it was
that split of the double team by Kimba
that created that waddell opportunity to
split here collapsed the defense wide
open three
thickness here of Jalen Brown here gets
all the way to the cup with the left
hand
taste knocked it away with his defense
here comes hammer it off to Walker and
up ball movement man movement absolutely
beautiful textbook Jess use your speed
gets by Washington all the way to the
cup to get his first who manufactures
and stuff right this is a terrific pass
by Walker look in one way throw on the
other and Brown does not disappoint
talking about earlier a smart play
they're not to take on la this heads
muscle
[Applause]
[Music]
Marcus here due to Falls got to go to
LaMarcus Aldridge in the Lok Lak get the
format in LA in the low block quit
messing around with it on the perimeter
Duffman triple IC just hit for walking I
got the three the hard way shot but he
had Haywood wide open as well but then
he cuts to the basket on that kid Walker
drive and I don't know how in the world
[Music]
Tatum underneath one or those birdies
coming out of a timeout on the perimeter
but they're also posting they've posted
up more than we are
mr. Damon Britt Randall comes off to
Tatum is five on four he's brown inside
the Williams he loses
[Music]
in this time 88 74 years
[Music]
just about to say you got a step to the
basket no steps up to stop Hill Walker
gets it right back to Williams now to
Tatum for seven
[Music]
[Applause]
5:10 remaining pepper Walker his rudy
Gay you count on Yukon caresses was
Walker was his first touch takes it to
the basket to take a look at this jail
and brown to theis head porzingis gets
the dribble back
makes it hard to the basket this good
play by Jaylon Brown comes off the pick
as man as behind him shots come up with
the loose ball
[Applause]
off they go and beautiful pass brown out
in front finishes it off
[Music]
yeah I love that I love
Kemba takes it
[Applause]
let's see Tembe he's got a big guy on
him imagism and knows he'd be able to
get it off drive to the basket waste
some time here Brown 1:14 left to play
1:13 for Boston 102 take a look let's
walk a drop there big guy
got him dancing